hey what's up guys my name is Deshawn ah
welcome to episode 22 of game
programming so yesterday we took a look
at the sprite class and actually
managing that and making that encoding
that blah blah blah
to make it um load sprites essentially
from a sprite sheet and today we're
actually going to move on to displaying
the sprite so if I actually launch the
game right now you'll see that we just
have this grid of colors which is
fantastic actually it looks really cool
and it's what represents our our arm our
map after every color is a different
tile basically and if we move around
you'll see that well we can move around
which is pretty damn awesome that's what
we've got so far I'm running at two and
a half thousand FPS which is insane so
that's great that's amazing
now we need to actually display the
sprite that we've loaded so yesterday we
created this amazing grass texture which
I'm probably just gonna put up on the
internet for sale because people are
gonna want to get their hands on this we
want to actually load that into into our
game and and display that instead of
these sort of things here so to do that
we just have to utilize what we've
created so first of all we've threaded a
way to create a sprite sheet right now
we actually know where the sprite sheet
is right now don't we because we created
it and it's actually in if we go to out
into if we go into it into the directory
of our game you'll see here we created a
folder called res shuffle resources and
inside that is a folder called textures
so how do we actually access this
physical spreadsheet file now it's
pretty simple because here we've
actually specified a path which will int
on it which will in turn actually you
know read the which in turn you know
we've got our our code here buffered
image to actually read the image from
that path and load it into our memory
and then we've applied that image into
our pixel array so we need to actually
run this somehow when you create a new
sprite shape now let's do it right over
here let's create a public static sprite
sheet again static means there's only
one instance of it and that it's this
you know because of that is accessible
throughout every class without actually
instantiating this class public means we
can use it anywhere you know the deal
we'll name it on will name at when I'm
at like tiles or something equals new
you spritesheet and now we're gonna fill
out all this stuff so first of all we
actually have to get access to this
resources folder we don't have access to
it right now all right
it's not just in there because remember
we've credit is so Java doesn't know all
right this is a follow of the needs to
be done so in order to do this we
actually to right click on our project
thing in the internet eclipse hit
properties then click on Java build path
all right and then under libraries make
sure it's under libraries we have to hit
add class folder now you'll see that
it's not here and you might be like why
what's up with that bro my folders there
if I go into the directory here there is
a res folder why is it not appearing
here now it's very simple you haven't
actually refreshed this thing so I've
actually done this on purpose to
demonstrate to you guys what what what
actually happens if you don't refresh it
and how to how to fix this problem
because a lot of you guys are hope
you're gonna encounter this problem so
in order to do this get out of all this
go back to your normal view right click
on your project and then select refresh
and now if you if we go back into
properties back into build path back
into libraries and add class folder you
will see that it's actually appeared
here and so as our textures folder so
let's just check the box at the res
folder and hit OK now you'll see
actually figure out our package Explorer
it's got like a little logo next to it
like like the same one that these
reference library sort of do that means
that now is part of our build path and
it will actually be included when java
compiler our program ok so now that
we've done that because our res res
classes our res folders order is already
included we don't really need to um we
don't really need to actually access it
we just need to access the folders in it
so when you actually specify the path
don't start the path at the resource
default it started at whatever the in
the results is folders we're not so now
cases textures so it's a string as you
can see so we do a little um quotation
marks and now make sure you start off
with a forward slash ok it will not work
if you don't have a forward slash if you
just type in textures like that and then
for
/wex pride shape NJ it will not work you
actually need to type forward slash
textures full-size spreadsheet of PNG
huge huge huge warning alright you need
to do that and then we have unspecified
assess fire size which in this case is
256 256 because our um because that's
the resolution of our thing if we
actually go here and you can see over
here that our dimensions are 256 by 256
of our size is 256 now that we've done
that how sprite shade is kind of it's
loaded into our memory now as cache -
it's ready to use throughout our project
if we go back into sprite first of all
we actually we've got this grass thing
right we've this is what we did
yesterday but we've got null here all
right because we haven't we didn't
actually create this sprite shade thing
now it's here and now we need to change
that all right now we've created a tile
sprite sheet now we need to actually
insert that instead of this null thing
so type in sprite sheet dot tiles
instead of null all right if you have no
there it will crash one other thing is
that this is in the top left corner so
it should be zero zero I was just
demonstrating that yesterday that's a
huge error as well that happens we'll
just get up you just get this this thing
instead of the grass - this versa that's
a tip all right so now we've constructed
all these things we're actually ready to
actually draw our sprite now I'm just
going to do it in the quick dirty way
just so you guys can see what it looks
like but all this code that we've pretty
much done here will be moved eventually
into its own like level class which will
actually draw the level so um it's just
temporary again
this is I'm just showcasing all the all
the individual techniques and then I'll
put them into into different classes
just so you guys can actually get
something on the screen as fast as
possible and see how it sort of
constructs so instead of our pixels here
because remember what you see on the
screen is comprised of pixels right so
at the moment we've set our pixels right
here equal to tiles tile index which in
turn are basically just colors
instead of this though we can wipe that
out we actually need to set it equal to
our sprite so sprite dot grass dot
pixels so our sprites pixels X again
using this X's in the for loop right
over here X and 15 right because if we
go
obviously the x value over here actually
goes to width that's when it stops and
obviously our sprites are only sixteen
by sixteen so in order to keep it
contained and we'll actually loop that
sprite throughout every pixel on our
screen we actually new type and 15
otherwise it'll crash with an array
index out of bounds exception plus y and
15 and then times the size of our sprite
so it should be sprite out size I don't
think that field is public so if we go
into sprite you'll see that we actually
have private final in size we'll change
that to public final in size and that
should be fine oh it's not static should
be static all right
obviously if it's static and I can't
have a static because of its static then
we obviously can't initialize it when
this gets created
so we'll probably just type 16 here I
was like there yeah although technically
if you really want to do it correctly
which would just probably go sprite dog
grass dot size and make this public and
there you go so that's the technical
correct correct way of doing it again
it's just equal to 16 so yeah if we hit
our little button here you'll say that
our world is now comprised of these
amazing um little grassy thing is
basically this texture load over and
over again so yeah
that's how we actually draw that texture
onto the screen you can see that we
actually can't move around now again we
can but it's just not it's not working
correctly because we're not dealing with
you know we're not doing it correctly
but that's how you get at it that's
basically that had the technique that
we'll be using to get our texture to the
screen will simply be setting pixels
equal to this so yeah make sure to take
all that code down remember that I did
actually rename this public final in
size to public it was private before and
what else and yeah in your actual sprite
make sure you add projectiles into the
parameters and you should be fine
all right so tomorrow probably take a
look at them I don't know we'll just
continue on with our game I guess I
haven't actually thought of what I want
to do tomorrow but yeah so we can delete
Colin deck now and that is how that
works so yeah I hope you enjoyed this
episode of game programming if you did
please hit the like button and I'll see
you guys see you guys tomorrow
bye guys
you